[Música]
la crisis climática y la defensa de la
Democracia fueron los protagonistas del
encuentro que tuvieron los presidentes
Joe biden y Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
en la casa blanca a su salida de la
reunión Lula reiteró que Brasil está de
vuelta en el panorama mundial
Nicaragua le quitó la nacionalidad a los
222 presos políticos que desterró el 9
de febrero el tribunal de apelaciones de
Managua confirmó la decisión luego de
ratificar una nueva ley que le retira a
la ciudadanía a todos los condenados por
traición a la patria conversamos con uno
de los opositores
y más de 90 incendios forestales siguen
activos en Chile seis países incluyendo
cinco latinoamericanos ya enviaron
refuerzos para combatir las llamas y la
ministra del interior Carolina Toa
anunció que llegará un grupo forense
desde Italia para indagar Cómo se
originaron las conflagraciones ampliamos
desde Chile
Bienvenidos a las noticias que France 24
le dedica a América Mi nombre es María
Clara calle el presidente Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva se encontró por primera
vez con su homólogo estadounidense Joe
biden dentro de la Casa Blanca
discutieron la defensa de la democracia
y una vez fuera Lula centró su breve
rueda de prensa de la lucha contra la
crisis climática biden afirmó que Brasil
y Estados Unidos superaron un examen al
enfrentar el asalto al Capitolio en 2021
y el ataque a la plaza de los tres
poderes en Brasilia el 8 de enero en
cuanto a la lucha ambiental se esperaba
algún anuncio para que Estados Unidos
respalde la financiación del fondo a
amazonía que combate la deforestación en
Brasil pero Lula aclaró que no hablaron
al respecto sino que le pidió a los
países ricos que se hagan responsables
por su contaminación
nuestros valores compartidos y nuestros
fuertes lazos entre nuestra gente hacen
que Brasil y Estados Unidos
especialmente aquí en los grandes
desafíos globales nos pongan en la misma
página particular y especialmente la
crisis
climáticas en los últimos años la selva
amazónica fue invadida por la falta de
racionalidad política la irracionalidad
humana porque teníamos un presidente que
mandaba a la gente a deforestar los
buscadores ilegales de oro ingresaban a
las reservas de los pueblos indígenas
Nicaragua le quitó la nacionalidad a los
222 presos políticos que liberó de las
cárceles el pasado jueves para
desterrarlos y enviarlos a Estados
Unidos el tribunal de apelaciones de
Managua ratificó la ley 1145 que aprobó
la asamblea nacional el jueves y que le
retire a la ciudadanía a todo el que sea
condenado por traición a la patria
hablamos con Max Jerez un líder
estudiantil opositor quien fue condenado
a 13 años de prisión y ha estado dentro
del grupo de desterrados él nos contó
Cómo interpreta la acción de Ortega de
enviarlos a otro país e inhabilitarlos
para acceder a cargos públicos
Bueno yo creo que detrás de esta acción
se esconde la profunda derrota una
derrota más de la dictadura que tuvo que
ceder ante la presión de todos los
nicaragüenses que demandaban la libertad
inmediata de todos los prisioneros
políticos de todos los correos de
conciencia que estaban siendo
injustamente encarcelados enjuiciados y
condenados y creo que el hecho de que
Ortega haya tenido que ceder en la
liberación de personas a las cuales en
horas previas se les habían dado
sentencias absurdas de 10 años 13 años
de que se le habían cancelado ciertos
derechos y que los haya tenido que
liberar inmediatamente es una profunda
derrota porque no se puede traducir de
otra forma y sobre yo espero y estoy
consciente de que Nicaragua necesita una
salida una medida así no es la solución
que Nicaragua no es la única solución
que nicaragüense necesita los presos
políticos son solamente uno de los
síntomas del profundo problema que
encierra Nicaragua bajo la dictadura de
Daniel Ortega este problema esencial Es
la falta de democracia la falta de
libertades la falta de estabilidad en el
país que se traduce en otras cosas como
El Éxodo masivo en nicaragüense que
hemos visto jóvenes del campo abandonar
las fincas las ciudades abandonar las
los centros de producción agrícola del
país porque no creen ya que tienen un
futuro en este país creo que Nicaragua
va a necesitar un profundo proceso de
diálogos Genuino que pase por abrir las
puertas de Nicaragua a la democracia y a
la libertad de manera definitiva
más de 500 brigadistas extranjeros están
desplegados en el centro sur de chile
apagando los incendios forestales que ya
dejan 24 muertos y más de 370.000
hectáreas quemadas dentro de la ayuda se
cuenta un equipo de trabajo forense que
llegará desde Italia para investigar
cómo comenzaron los fuegos nuestra
corresponsal Patricia Luna nos amplía
nueva jornada en el combate de los
incendios que asolan desde hace más de
una semana al centro sur de chile y que
tienen a tres regiones bajo estado de
catástrofe el ñuble bío bío y Lara ocaña
fueron 321 los focos que combatieron los
diversos brigadistas bomberos fuerzas
armadas desplegadas en terrenos también
muchos voluntarios 94 de ellos
especialmente activos varios focos en la
comuna en la que nos encontramos walkie
se pudo ver fuego llamaradas desde
varios puntos de su Horizonte varios
foques que sucedían a la vez la ministra
del interior Carolina toja anunció que
se va a traer a un grupo de expertos
italianos para investigar el origen de
estos juegos ya hay 30 personas
detenidas por presunta intencionalidad
en el origen de estos fuegos y se va a
seguir una técnica forense para
determinar Cómo se produjeron varias
personas de las que con las que
hablábamos aquí varios vecinos de walkie
también denunciaban posible
intencionalidad en el origen de estos
incendios que vienen casti con fuerza y
han consumido más de 340.000 hectáreas
según afirman las autoridades dejado más
de dos decenas de personas fallecidas
2000 personas heridas y más de 1.250
casas totalmente destruidas Pero además
de eso también incendios que en un
sector especialmente rural y agrícola
dejan a muchas personas sin una forma de
continuar ganándose la vida el
presidente Gabriel borics visitó la
comuna de quillón en el núcleo y también
anunció que ha estado en conversaciones
con varios de sus padres
latinoamericanos para establecer un
posible equipamiento que incluyera
helicópteros y también aviones de Última
Generación para combatir los incendios
en toda la región
la comisión permanente del Congreso de
Perú recomendó acusar por tres delitos
al expresidente Pedro Castillo esto por
las irregularidades que encontraron
meses atrás en las obras del puente
tarata segundo y que ha salpicado a
castillo de corrupción lo que sigue es
que el congreso vote en pleno Y si
ratifica la decisión el caso pasará a
ser investigado por la fiscalía Por otra
parte la presidenta Dina boluarte le
insistió al congreso para que adelante
las elecciones generales de Perú y no
sean en 2026 como están programadas
hasta ahora los legisladores han
rechazado las dos peticiones de boluarte
y otros dos proyectos similares
temporalmente El Congreso de la
República la nación indígena y busca
regresar a sus lugares ancestrales
originalmente estaban asentados en la
alta amazonía occidental pero hace cerca
de 80 años fueron expulsados por las
disputas fronterizas entre Ecuador y
Perú en 2017 presentaron una demanda a
Ecuador para obtener el título de
propiedad de 42 mil hectáreas pero a la
fecha no han recibido respuesta Max
Pérez Gallardo nos cuenta la historia
en el corazón de la selva late
resistencia el pueblo sieco país sigue
la lucha por recuperar el territorio
ancestral que las delimitaciones
modernas les han arrebatado el
colonialismo el extractivismo y los
conflictos armados de la región han sido
algunas causas de su expulsión de
pequeña nombre ancestral del territorio
originario de los ecopai ahora quieren
volver a su hogar nosotros desde que
empecemos a tener nuestros pequeños
territorios en el Ecuador y hoy seguimos
luchando por territorio por los 80 años
seguidos son una lucha que no podemos
dejar porque sin territorio sin cultura
no podemos existir la nacionalidad
la gente de colores nombre mitológico de
la nación es uno de los 14 grupos
indígenas reconocidos en Ecuador donde
el 7% de su población se identifica como
tal la marginalización de las
poblaciones originarias es un problema
histórico en América Latina el contraste
entre la cosmovisión ancestral y los
estándares de la modernidad hacen
complicados el respeto a la otra edad
indígena
al inicio cuando estaba estudiando en el
colegio
había mucha discriminación Digamos como
cuando uno era indígena te decían Por
qué estás aquí eres una indígena O
cuando hablaba decían tú no salte de
aquí indígena me decían
un pueblo en constante oposición desde
la llegada al continente de los antiguos
imperios europeos La Rebeldía ha sido su
herramienta principal para proteger su
identidad hoy la resistencia sigue en
pie hasta aquí las noticias Gracias por
estar con nosotros
[Música]